how can we accept such a narrative of
hate speech and racism directed at us
this is qatar's Minister for labor
showing the European Parliament what he
calls slanderous allegations and a
malicious campaign against his country
the football World Cup has put Qatar
under the microscope especially on
migrant workers who provide almost all
of qatar's Labor
rapid infrastructure growth for the
entire country with investment over 200
billion dollars required millions of
workers those states have relied on this
transient Workforce for years and often
Economic Opportunity came at the cost of
many human rights
so the World Cup was a catalyst for
change I can say certainly is
accelerated the labor reforms the ILO
works all over the world and rarely do
we see change happening at this pace Max
tunion heads the international labor
offices at the chapter emphasizing the
need to do more he says qatars Made
strides to amend laws and the kafala or
sponsorship system and provide
compensation for victims the sponsorship
program barred employees from changing
jobs or employers
but he also admits criticism over
migrant issues such as worker debts has
not always been objective this relates
to the total number of South Asian
Nationals who have died in Qatar over a
10-year period it doesn't make any
distinction between whether these are
work related deaths or non-work related
death in fact it even includes people
who are not even economically active so
it's really important to understand a
little bit more the context in Qatar the
workforce is incredibly diverse South
Asians are working in every sector of
the economy across all income levels and
they make up a huge proportion of the
overall population 50 to 60 of the
population the figure of 6500 is
certainly misleading but that misleading
number keeps being quoted on the media
someone talks about 6 500 victims
another says ten thousand and a third
one talks about fifteen thousand as if
there was a competition there shouldn't
be any politicizing or using
misinformation so we ask that you refer
to official sources like ILO workers
have told us anonymously about some
companies not paying them on time and
problems changing employers officials
acknowledge gaps and point at response
times getting better but they also want
the media to make the distinction
between companies that break the law and
the reforms being implemented by Qatar
in addition to worker related issues
thousands of single men have been forced
from their accommodations although this
was a municipality issue rather than a
labor one for many workers trying to
make ends meet it's difficult to make
that distinction
Lottery drivers had to leave their
belongings as accommodations were sealed
without notice as many of them were
living in shared rooms to save money
there was no electricity in the room no
water we couldn't go to bathroom the
next day we all had to work some didn't
have a place to sleep including me one
night I slept in the vehicle I drive
officials in the government admit the
implementation of reforms needs work and
assured the world that the World Cup is
just one milestone for the country's
long-term Vision the reforms are based
on Qatar Vision 2030. this Vision
clearly states the needs for reforms
linked to the issues the World Cup has
sped up these reforms
labor unions say in order for more Gulf
States to make necessary changes for
migrant workers the world must
acknowledge the reform while pointing
out the Caps they're concerned that a
vicious campaign against Qatar could
quote decapitate the good work done over
the years